today's topic yes we got an another
video from blue therapy
before we start this okay because i saw
a lot of people confused in the comments
these are actors this is all an act this
is not real it's entertainment we're
just having fun
the lady is not a therapist she's an
actress
even the therapist is not she's a legit
hi let's talk about hearing aids asia
looks good yeah but with your heart
condition we're going to need to find
specialist traveling sharon is it that
much of a problem that a woman in her
mid to late
40s is in her dressing gown in her own
home
oh hello we haven't met caroline newton
dunn
this is all scripted okay so you guys
can stop losing your mind
okay people in the comments taking this
too seriously this is just entertainment
the only reason we're watching this is
this is our like sense of national
geographics we're just judging people
from the uk based off your television
[Music]
you know them we're there people are
like hey you know what
why does preach sounds like he's from
east whatever
no it's from birmingham that's what the
accent is from birmingham
bugs i'm just imitating mike skinner
that's why i'm trying to imitate that's
who i'm trying to imitate
i'm trying to emulate but anyways every
time you do that accent you know what
i'm thinking
are you dizzy blood are you dizzy
shout out to a kid although it i know i
know he's in trouble right now
but uh good movie good morning what do
you do oh the people in the comments
about to let you know
oh yeah let me know what he did
i like how you're laughing like that and
the people in the comments like no [ __ ]
don't laugh
but it was oh yeah is that bad hey
people the comments
a few from the uk okay all right you
know
just leave some comments correct
as far as that actor goes watch how
quickly preach is going to be walking
away okay
you want to talk about a rise and fall
this man went from
award show
yeah but anyways let's get to this
episode we've actually been together
for a year have you had many
relationships this actually is my first
relationship um but i have obviously
dated in the past
um but yeah this is my first
relationship and yeah going strong
a year mostly things are going well then
i mean
to an extent max's boyfriend we speak a
lot
as you know wait me and mata speak a lot
isn't it like she told me that when she
addresses the situation
he's able technology and he just moves
on do you want me you didn't care less
about your break your friend's boyfriend
just do something that probably
well maybe you should chat him a bit
more how about this yeah don't compare
me
you're moving mad listen i'm gonna say
this bro
don't be doing comparisons don't don't
because whatever you're hearing from
your girlfriend about their relationship
you're only hearing the good
stuff when it's good all right and you
only hear the bad stuff when it's bad
you don't get a good balanced view of
most people's relationships so when you
sit there comparing them
it's like yo if you if you so happy with
that person then go date them go be a
sister wife or go find this twin brother
[ __ ] why you [ __ ] with me yeah yeah
but you know what you know what he does
then go date him i am who i am and if
you don't like that don't like that but
don't be comparing me to others
you think i'd go up to my girl and be
like yo my ex was way
hotter get in the gym the [ __ ] out of
here
then why you why you not with your ass
right now yeah
parrying [ __ ] you'll be out
you're doing the most
yeah don't compare me i've had enough
reserve conversations with your
friends talking about our sex life our
family life this just this needs to stop
now is this
um quite an influential person in your
life
do they influence you yeah mata is my
best friend so we speak a lot about our
relationship
i'm an open person like i'm happy to i'm
happy to speak about
our sex life i'm happy to speak about
things that we do like
you might be an open person but you
shouldn't be open with
other people's lives you want to be open
without your own life that's fine
but when you are involved with somebody
else you have to also respect their
privacy
meaning it's not because i tell you
something that you have therefore the
right to go tell everyone else the same
way it's not because i share an intimate
moment with you that you can go share
with everyone else the same way
if i have a video that i do with a girl
doesn't mean i can share with all my
friends the same way
just because we [ __ ] doesn't mean go
tell everyone about our sex life do you
understand
and there is a certain level of uh
dislike that i personally have
for people who gossip which is why i've
said in another video to young men
don't kiss and tell because an intimate
moment that a girl shares with you you
shouldn't be go sharing all your boys
everything that she did for you all
right and if you're gonna do at least
keep it anonymous so that her privacy is
respected you could be like hey man i
had this great experience
yeah i mean she did some next level
thing but don't say who it is
understand there's a certain level of
respect that you should have for people
that you bring into your life
and understand unless you've had that
conversation with them don't be sharing
that with everyone so that's just
something to think about even when
people have done like bad things to me
i haven't aired out their names i
haven't gone out and told everybody who
they are
oh mask what because it's not my place
to it's a private conversation it's a
private incident i'm not gonna blast
that on everybody so
there's just a bit of privacy that i
think people don't take into
consideration and it shows a lack of
respect
and consideration are you moving mad
i'm telling you this [ __ ] and you keep
on doing it i'll cut you off
no problem cutting that [ __ ] off that's
a no-no
oh okay word cool deborah does this
thing that i actually hate like she
loves comparing me to other people
other guys like no one likes getting
compared to other people like why would
you do
this conversation enough times honestly
just needs to stop it pisses me off so
much like
once you realize this is all acting it
becomes so obvious when they're doing
their little monologues
how many takes did he have to do to get
that out once you know that it takes it
takes the shine away i
i find this worse for two reasons
one they pretend that it's not fake
they pretend like and they pretend like
this woman's actually a therapist so
people who are watching this are
thinking
this is what therapy looks like yup and
it doesn't
that's not which is something which is
something that we have to acknowledge
about this because that's where
internalizing it it's important to know
what's fake and what's not
i don't want people to not go to therapy
because they think it looks like that
because it doesn't
she is not a therapist and and
and not only are they not stating that
it's fake they're actually trying to
pretend it's real
right like deborah's doing instagram
lives where she's like
why are you guys getting mad why are you
pressed it's our relationship
like they're not all actors anybody's
acting shocked you know
in asking me what i bring to the table
that was very very
shocking and yes it definitely is a real
thing to say because jamal and i
both full well know what i bring to the
table
and so that's the part that rubs me the
wrong way when i'm watching this at the
moment i'm happy
and how does that make you feel knowing
that she's talking to this friend of
hers it just sounds like my girlfriend's
a taipei
i don't like girls that just be speaking
too too much like i hate your friends
but when it comes to situations that's
about myself especially my family life
and hold on if you talk to your friend
and then after that we're gonna go out
she's gonna come out over or whatever
and like either she's gonna come over
we're gonna go out and [ __ ]
like a couple thing or whatever whatnot
or your girl comes over
and your girl
tries to talk to me about [ __ ] that we
have
so eric
when's the baby because i know that my
girl been talking about my and we had a
conversation about a baby
with my girl and then now your
girlfriend talks to me about that
i'mma stay calm and [ __ ] i'm like oh
this and that and that and that and that
and when your friend leaves i'ma ask you
to pack your bag
and leave i'd be like i told you not to
do that now your friend is talking to me
about our business that's a no
back your back no but pack your bag no
but hey
i am done here oh
oh man are you moving
mud i don't talk about our [ __ ] to
anybody
you gonna like now your friends gonna
talk to
that's some high school [ __ ] you go out
with a girl
and then her friend comes like you're
gonna take care of my girl okay
shut your [ __ ] mouth shut up in your
business where did you hear that was a
bad boy and stuff like that
yeah i hate that [ __ ] uh you gonna think
shut your
whole mouth do i know are you bloody
where where have we raised the lambs
together what the [ __ ] are you talking
about that's right
who are you dead who are you that's some
that's some childish [ __ ] yeah take care
of my girl you better tell me
or what i better drink or what
what are you gonna do you're gonna have
to deal with what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do
you know what i'm cool you take care of
your girl
[ __ ] you talking about [ __ ] is dumb
high school [ __ ] don't do [ __ ] like that
and you're talking about family life
yeah family life
what was it about your family yeah so
let me just put some context into it so
she spoke about a situation between me
and my mother
okay so yeah me and my mom we have a bit
of a
what did i say here and there
relationship sort of thing so she's got
her
her friend mansar um and just told her
about the situation i'm thinking has
nothing to do with
your friends i wasn't telling her
i wasn't telling her about the situation
i was just telling her how
it was affecting me and jamelle that's
what i was saying and what advice did
she give you
she just said like that you're moving
out soon you know just general chitchat
like why'd you care
about the conversation about general
chitchat am i just
it's genuine chitchat you need to
understand that i'm like why are you
bored now
okay that's childish i literally do not
see an issue with telling my best friend
about my relationship like it's what
girls do
it's what we do it's how we like to
communicate we like to share with our
besties like
master likes to hear my stories and i
like to hear hers and that's why dudes
share your tapes
do you see where this logic goes just
sharing private information about people
exactly it's not right that's not right
both of them are not right
that's not right that's what i'm saying
that's what we're saying right now we're
not saying that
sharing tapes is all right or it's an
excuse to both of it is not right it's
not right
stop sharing so much information like
that it's not right
thing that happened between just not
right
both yeah it's not right not a single
time i think jamel probably has an issue
with it because
he's not acting right if he was doing
the most now he knew that i was happy
with his behavior
then maybe he wouldn't mind me telling
matza yeah but you would still
use anyways it's all fake so who cares
i've just been having fun honestly i'm
really not stressed at all about this
yeah but it's just one of those things
where you know on a real [ __ ] like i
really dislike women who gossip and i've
heard of women who've gone on to tell
others about like experiences that they
had with me and
i've always looked at those women like
they were garbage afterwards like i
wanted nothing to do with them
not even like gorgeous yeah yeah i
looked at them like they
were like garbage ah i see yeah
yeah yeah yeah so for me it's just a
general dislike i have because i'm like
listen i respected your privacy i would
never think of doing that to you but
that's how you
okay so i see how you view me that's
fine you just don't respect me so
that's how you move we ain't got no we
don't have to associate like move on my
dick
um but generally i'm just trying to be
respectful of the people i'm involved
within
i'm not saying i'm always successful but
i wouldn't just normally go out of my
way to do something like that so that's
just stuff i dislike personally
private stuff should be kept private
progress and and
and it's funny because you know we have
this whole thing with locker room talk
and how men do stuff but like
you know women violate boundaries in
private all
the time all the time and this is not to
say it's good for one gender or not
that's not the point
is that we address the fact that men's
locker room talk we talk about how like
what men say behind closed doors
probably but we don't listen or
violating boundaries all the time and
that's just one thing i've never liked
that's why they have never never left
that whole gossip thing
i'm just not a fan
i get you yeah so oftentimes just based
on feelings and things that are not true
just like astrology
yeah it's like it's not even also
like intimacy sometimes you could just
ask a girl out she says no you're like
cool have a good day
and this girl then told the whole town
that you asked her out
for what reason you already gave the man
an
l it was just fine and now you gonna go
and just let it
no but that's that's pride that's pride
that's
that's pride that's just hey you know
like i'm hot like that
yes you know who asked me out it's that
person
i said totally said no like [ __ ] that
dude but he asked me out like he had the
i heard girls say that of course yeah
happy hour is a great hour to
just see the worst out of people bro
people are busy people are bugging so
so yeah that's pretty much it like i
said this whole thing's fake
so i don't really care that much if you
guys want to see us cover more of this
we'll probably do another episode of it
but it'll only be on patreon
so for those who want to see us cover
more uk content you guys can go to the
patreon
and get exclusive access to these kinds
of videos
as well as a whole range of early access
videos
and other exclusive story times videos
with preach talking all this good stuff
so
head over there and that is it for
today's video hope you
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
you